strangers more than 1,000 miles away
from a lost dog's home helped him find
his way back this husky named Sinatra
look at his eyes slipped out the front
door of his family's home in Brooklyn
New York
18 months ago the five year old dog
somehow ended up all the way down the
East Coast in a place called Seffner
Florida that's just outside Tampa Jim
Axelrod shows us how two families and
their friends work together to get
Sinatra home again Jim I love this story
good morning so - hi good morning it was
March of 2017 when Sinatra took off
running from the Willis family home
during a package delivery now anyone
who's ever lost a pet knows the hole
that creates in your heart but making
this even more painful with Sinatra's
connection to this family's tragedy
after being gone for the last year and a
half the Willis family's beloved pet dog
Sinatra is finally back home this
morning when the message arrived that
Sinatra had been found I can't even
imagine what went through your head I
didn't believe it I didn't think was
true I didn't think it was possible
that's because the message came from
more than a thousand miles away near
Tampa Florida three weeks ago 13-year
old rose Verrill saw Sinatra wandering
her neighborhood while she was waiting
at her school bus stop he just had this
thing about him
that was like I have been with a family
before I've been with a family probably
most of my life Rose and her mother took
Sinatra to the vet who found an ID chip
in the dog but some of the owners
contact information was inaccurate with
what little info they did have the
Verrill family used social media to
connect with less Moore Willis and
deliver the unbelievable news there's a
piece that's back that we didn't have
for a year now there's a piece of Zion
this back yeah yeah Sinatra had joined
the Willis family as a fourteenth
birthday present for their daughter Zion
the teenager was killed in a shooting
accident at a friend's house in November
of 2015 18 months later Sinatra ran away
in light of the tragedy that happened to
their family the fact that there
able to get back this part of her I
think
that's truly amazing what's also amazing
is how Sinatra made it back home once
the owners were found Friends of the
barrels and the Willises took turns over
two days driving Sinatra hundreds of
miles up the East Coast
let's more willis drove the last leg of
the trip himself if Zion were here with
me right now she'd be saying hurry up
daddy drive fast is that faster we got
to get him we gotta get him he was
reunited with Sinatra in southern New
Jersey Sinatra and Sinatra finally made
it all the way home last night back to
the family that sees him as a connection
to Zion more than three years after her
death she loved him it was obvious they
they got along incredibly they had a
bond that none of us had with them up
until that point it was tough it's still
tough sometimes but I'm glad he's back
it's it's a part of our family back it
would seem a big part of this story will
forever remain a mystery
just how Sinatra got all the way to
Florida to begin with but the Willis
family says they are content to live
with never knowing just as long as they
have this linked to their late daughter
back a link they had given up hope of
ever seeing again we needed a story like
this today there's so much negativity in
the world it just shows you what happens
when humanity kicks in people work
together a good of social media exactly
having good friends that it will drive
hundreds of miles a long way with it
yeah I hate them not knowing though I
want to know where is Sinatra been and
you said we'll never know understood
okay that's right and there's an
opportunity for a memoir yes right also
with blue eyes I should know
[Laughter]